okay I promise you were gonna talk about
education for a minute I realized that
in the midst of fighting this ridiculous
view of education that's floating around
that I had joined hands with some of you
that I didn't didn't mean to let me tell
you what I mean or I had I made the
appearance too which would have been by
the way hypocritical and I'm if anything
not a hypocrite I'm unbelievably
consistent I never do I never tell you
to do anything on the show that I
wouldn't do or that I'm not currently
doing or haven't done you know something
along those lines
I just don't including advertising
endorsements I just don't life's too
short for me so I saved up and paid for
all three Ramsey kids to go to college I
brainwashed them to go to college
we're doing the same thing with the next
generation with my grandkids to go to
college it would be inconsistent for me
to tell you not to go to college or not
to save money to go to college because I
truly believe you should go to college
that's a general statement are there
some people who are not cut out for
college sure absolutely and I'm not mad
at you and I'm not talking down to you
if that's you and you're gonna go get a
technology certification and you're
gonna study and get your microphone
Microsoft certs or you're gonna go to
trade school and be a heating and air
guy or gal I got no issue with that at
all but be careful about people telling
you you're not cut out for college and
be very careful to not tell other people
they're not cut out for college and
here's why there is a direct correlation
between
education and income even though there
are stupid people studying ridiculously
stupid left-handed you know I got a
master's degree in left-handed puppetry
it's but two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars getting a master's degree in
sociology a lady told me the other day
that's dumb
because the field of sociology does not
pay enough to justify that expenditure
that's why it's dumb and she was in debt
two hundred fifty thousand dollars so we
hear these bizarro over charges by
ridiculously expensive primarily private
schools and people going hundreds of
thousands of dollars in the student loan
debt and our meandyou
normal people's visceral reaction is
well it's reached the point that college
is just stupid and a bunch of you are
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
and that's what I was reacting against
with our last caller before the bottom
of the hour well college is just not for
everyone is the saying but what that
means is college is not for anyone let
me just tell you ninety-eight percent of
you need to go to school well today if
you understand I've got this and I've
got that listen I think when I was a kid
we didn't have a D or a TD or ADHD we
didn't know those initials they called
me hyperactive hyper couldn't sit still
couldn't pay attention but you know what
I learned to sit still and pay attention
I couldn't read coming out of the first
grade I shouldn't have gone into the
second grade my mother talked them into
it I mean coming out of second grade I'm
sorry my third grade teacher Miss Mary
Jane hurt my fourth grade teacher miss
Pratt taught me to read and now I have
written several New York Times
bestselling books several and sold
millions tens of millions of copies
because I learned to sit still and pay
attention no does that mean everybody's
ADHD you know I'm not getting into that
fight that's not my point
my point is is when you look at someone
and say you're not college material
that's what they used to say you're not
college material you should just go off
and do so-and-so you might have just
ruined their dad young life so let's not
let's teach people to dream about
getting an education and when I say
getting an education I mean going to a
reasonably priced institution where what
you spend is going to cause your income
to go up so much because you study
something that's applicable if you get a
good solid degree in a good solid
subject matter that businesses are
actually using in the marketplace by the
way businesses are we're freaking jobs
come from and so someone will hire you
or more likely to hire you because you
know something in a field not because
you have a degree because you know
something about marketing or you know
something about communications or you
know something about accounting or you
know something about whatever fill in
the blank studies you know you become a
nurse I don't care but you have to know
something to be a nurse you have to know
something it's a great career path by
the way you have to know something and
so don't let this ridiculous thing
that's happened in our culture where
people are overpaying for bad degrees
tremendously overpaying for bad degrees
and going deeply into debt for bad
degrees in subject areas no one should
have ever been studying because there's
no application for them in the
marketplace whatsoever it was an excuse
for rich people or dumb people to go to
school and get ripped off instead study
something at a reasonably priced
institution become smart read a book
take a class that's what a degree is so
my rant is simply this college is not a
bad idea college statistically speaking
is a great idea that's why we used to
say with great pride I'm the first one
in my family to get
college degree because it meant that you
were going to be more prosperous than
your family had previously been because
they had an education I'm about halfway
through David McCullough's book on John
Adams the education level of the signers
of the Declaration was astounding
astounding their quest for knowledge
their reading how voraciously they read
was astounding and these were very young
men how much Jefferson was in his
thirties he wrote the Declaration of
Independence you don't do that if you're
a fool you don't do that if you have not
been formally trained and your mind has
been trained and so my University of
Tennessee business degree has been worth
a bazillion times what I paid for it I
use it every day running this business
as everything they taught me perfect
no absolutely not so consequently I
brainwashed my children to go to college
and consequently I'm brainwashing my
grandkids to go to college now if one of
them has a learning disability that's a
different thing if one of them has a you
know it is just really going to do
something else they're going to work
with their hands they're going to be an
artist they're gonna do whatever that's
fine that's fine but this idea that you
can go and be an intern at Microsoft and
end up running Microsoft is complete BS
you can't it takes more sophistication
than that on-the-job training it doesn't
work that way folks so let's not throw
the baby out with the bathwater being
smart being educated in the right things
in the right way with reasonable price
structures is absolutely vital for most
people let's not lose the dream of
Americans being smart